prophet
remained in Mecca with his
companions. course, Quraish had
ramped up there aggression to
the point that it wasn't just
aggression. It was persecution.
and they persecuted the Muslim
in for one reason only. And
that was for their belief in
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. And
their disregard. or the
religion of polytheism and
idolatry. And because of this
decision, because of this
choice they decided to pursue
the Muslims Even those of them
who chose to leave peacefully,
were pursued and chased. And
very vicious rumors began to
swirl. to the point that at
every Hajj season, you know,
when when people would come
into Mecca during that time,
the sacred months in the
Islamic calendar are the same
sacred months the Quraish at
that time. We have four sacred
months. We have three of them
which are
subsequent. So, we have or or
sequential. We have
and Muharam. These three in a
row. This is the time for Hajj.
This was always the time for
Hajj. This was always the
season for Hajj. And those
three sacred months are the
same sacred months for Ibrahim
Alaihi Salam. This observation
of the sacred months that
Quraish had and this somewhat
at least their their claim to
really hold these sacred months
in high regard and their
reverence and veneration of
these sacred months is
something that was upon them
and amongst them since the time
of Ibrahim Alaihi Salam. There
were a number of things which
were practiced by Ibrahim,
practiced by Ismael, practiced
by their offspring and their
lineage all the way until the
prophet Muhammad reminances.
and so these sacred months are
the same sacred months in
Islam. The prophet
tells us that sacred months in
the book of Allah, in the
religion of Allah are for. They
are three sequential months. Or
successive months. We have the
eleventh 12th and first month
of the Islamic Lunar Calendar
which is and Muharam and then
we have the month of Rajab
Which is the seventh month. In
the Islamic lunar calendar. And
that seventh month that Rajab
month is the time for Umrah.
Omrah is a minor Hajj. It's a
visitation. And the reason why
these sacred months were
observed the main focus of
these sacred months is a
general ceasefire, a general
truce and war was something
that was frowned upon and
viewed to be a major, major
sin. That a person would fight
his enemy in Mecca or fight his
enemy in these sacred months.
Why? in order to give people
that are coming and going from
Mecca for the sake of
pilgrimage in order to give
them safe passage. Usually, it
was a month the month of or the
was to arrive at Mecca, a month
of to be there, and a month of
Muharam to return. To wherever
it is they came from. And since
Umrah is kind of off season and
it's much less intensive and
much less lengthy during the
month of Rajab. This was a
month that many people would
frequent the Kaaba for a kind
of minor visitation or Hajj.
However, they attested and
claimed and even boasted and
took great pride in the fact
that they observe this the
sacredness of these months but
really it was just talk. They
did not observe the sacredness
of these months. And they did
not observe the sacredness of
the haram of Mecca. They the
Muslims there. They persecuted
them. They would not harm an
animal there but the Muslims,
yes. They prohibited people and
barred people from coming to
the Kaaba, barred people from
simply because they were
Muslim. Likewise, did what is
called a Nasi. A Nasi is a type
of
type of a method of calculation
that they did to try to offset
the sacred months. So, if they
had planned something of
warfare or something that would
go against the sacredness of
those months, they would
calculate their calendar to
shift the name of that month to
the month before it or after
it, right? This is called the
Nasit. So, it was a very
superficial holiness, very
superficial claim that they
made with regards to their
reverence for the Kaaba,
reverence for the Haram, and
their reverence for these
sacred ones.
There aggression and
persecution of the Muslims
became so intense. That they
actively spread false rumors to
all of the tribes during the
months of sacred months. So,
when it's time for Hajj, they
would literally designate men,
certain men groups of men to
stand at all of the different
gates of Mecca that the
different tribes would arrive
through and as the tribes
arrive, hey, we have someone
here named Mohammed. He's got
people with him. They call
themselves Muslim. Make sure
that you listen to them.
this man is a a madman or this
man is a magician or he's a
soothsayer, he's a sorcerer, or
he's possessed by a devil and
stuff this. Don't listen
to him. Whatever you do, do not
allow him to entrance you with
his Quran. Now, obviously, this
had the opposite effect because
if they had just left it alone,
you know, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala had written and ordained
that this religion was going to
spread. And it was going to
spread not just in spite of its
antagonist but this religion is
going to spread largely because
of its antagonist. Meaning that
the prophet has said
he said that Allah is going to
spread this religion and raise
it in people's thought. Even if
upon thee even if by even even
through or even by the way of
this religion's antagonist.
Even by those who are sinful.
And so because they said all of
these things and human beings
naturally to hear stories
of chaos and stories of misery
stories of and they love to
hear rumors and things like
that. They peaked everyone's
curiosity. So, when everybody
came in, they're not curious.
Now, they're going to go out of
their way to catch a glimpse of
this Muhammad character that
they say that they're speaking
about. They're going to go out
of their way to try to hear
this Quran. What's so fantastic
about it? Why is Quraish acting
so scared of it? And Because of
these efforts, Islam spread all
the way to the far regions of
the Arab Peninsula and beyond
even before the prophet
migrated to Medina. And so,
when that happened, when when
people go back from Mecca to
wherever they came from, they
take their stories with them.
They take news with them. They
take information with them and
rumors of what other are doing
and what's going on and so one
of those things that they would
take back is the curious case
of the prophet Muhammad while
we were there we met a man. His
name was this. He recites
a book this. He claims
he's a messenger from Allah,
etcetera, etcetera. Now, people
that were not planning to go to
Hajj are going to go to Hajj
just to catch a a glimpse of
the Muslims and their prophet,
right? And so, this was a major
advancement for the Muslims.
Because
a person garners attention
Quarts attention. When Islam
gets into the mind and the
consciousness of the general
masses. If they come, to the
source of that religion, the
prophet Muhammad the Quran
being the most pure source of
the religion of Islam. They
will in awe of the of what they
hear and the message will have
been conveyed properly. And so
many of the people that heard
of him were curious, came to
catch a glimpse. They wanted to
kind of gawk at this person
that has Quresh. So indignated.
And would end up accepting
Islam. And going back to their
tribes and their families and
all far corners of the Arab
Peninsula and Arab world and
convey what it is they have
heard, convey what it is they
had learned and memorized and
so, the harder they tried to
put it out to put the light of
Islam out, the more intense it
became. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala said about this
He said Allah that they seek to
extinguish the light of Allah
with their mouths. But Allah
refuses but that his light be
perfected and completed upon
mankind. In spite of the
disbelievers and so, the harder
they tried to spread rumors
about Islam and so forth, the
more people started to accept
Islam and this is the way that
it will be until the end of
time. The message of Islam will
not be
transmitted under any light
except that his purity will
touch people's heart. And so,
as they saw that this was only
making things worse, Only
making them worse. It's only,
it's only in their mind. It's
only making the prophet more
relevant. It's only, it's only
causing to draw people to Islam
rather than hinder people from
Islam with these rumors. They
decided on another strategy.
And that strategy was to have a
financial embar go on the
prophet and anyone who is
affiliated with him and stands
between Quraish and the prophet
this was not just directed
towards the Muslims. This was
an active this is an act of war
When when when a place is
financially cut off,
importation, exportation.
Marriage, etcetera. There's an
act of war, right? And so, they
began to wage this warfare on
all of Benny Hashem.
So they got together and said
we all agree We are not going
to speak even. We're going to,
we are not going to marry to
these folks or marry from them.
We're not going to trade with
them. commerce, any kind of
financial aid or any kind of
trade when they come to buy
something from you, it is
illegal to sell them anything.
Right As a matter of fact,
we're going to all agree not
even to speak to them. We are
going to socially excommunicate
them and ostracize them. So,
this is what they decided to
do. And they directed this
towards Benihashem and Benil
Muktalib. The prophet tribe.
They decided anyone who is
affiliated with them, stands
with them, any antagonist of
them or sympathizer will not be
shown mercy and will be shown
the exact same treatment. So,
kind of you know, you're
either with us or you're with
them. If you're not with us, by
default, you're with them. and
so they got together to write
this. Writing something was
very, very rare. Only a select
is only very select things were
written down on paper They
would, it's kind of if you
if you think about it, right?
In our culture writing
something down on paper is not
a big deal, right? But if you
make a monument and engrave it,
that's kind of a big deal in
our culture. In that time,
writing something on paper is
essentially memorializing that
thing. That means that is a big
deal because there's only a
handful and when I say a
handful, I mean less than three
people in all of Quraish that
know how to actually read and
write. and that was the house
of Abu Sufian. Abu Sufian, his
son, etcetera. They were the
ones who were literate because
they had gone outside of the
Arab Peninsula and studied
Arabic lettering to be able to
have the skill to write. And
so, when they decide to write
something, it's only because
this thing is absolutely the
pinnacle of sacredness, right?
We have to understand the
significance of this. Imagine
with me something the
Geneva Convention right? We
know what the Geneva Convention
is. It was basically an
agreement in lieu of the World
Wars. That certain things would
not be used as an agreement
amongst warring countries.
Certain, you know, a lot of
things are added to it over the
over time. you know, certain
kinds of mines and landmines
and things that are that name
or torture a person, etcetera.
Any weapon that and they
have list of things in the
different countries sign or
agree to it. curiously,
America has not signed the
Geneva Convention but they
recognize it, right? I mean,
we don't really agree but
we agree. So, we haven't
officially signed it but we
recognize it. And so, this is
the same kind of thing. Imagine
all of these countries come
together and make this kind of
huge monumental timeless
agreement. This is the same
kind of thing that happened
between the tribes of Quraish.
They got together.
found someone literate to write
for them and they decided to
write down these conditions.
Abdul Qa He says
[Silence]
uncle. And others in his
status, in his bracket started
to accepted Islam. This was a
very big problem for them. And
so, they decided to do this or
undertake this embargo against.
Benny Hasham and Benny Almo
Talib. And they got together.
and they got a man named Baril
Ibn Amir Ibn Hashem. Is a
fitting name for him. In the
Arabic language is someone who
is deeply hated. Right? Now you
would wonder why would someone
name his son deeply hated. Well
because they did this to me and
deeply hated by their tribe's
enemies. This is what they
meant by Israel. Lot of these
names were changed by the
prophet when people would enter
into Islam. And so They got
this man Hashem and they told
him to write the following
contract. They will not sell or
trade or engage in any commerce
with Benny Hasham and Benny Al
Muktalib. They will not marry
from them or to them. They will
not speak with them and they
will not share company with any
of them. Until A step aside and
hand over the prophet
and so wrote this
and they took this document and
they hung it in the Kaaba. This
is the place they chose to hang
it. So, they're essentially
saying, this is the set most
sacred of sacred documents that
we must uphold and they hang
this in the Kaaba. They hang it
in the Kaaba. That they revered
obviously as the house of
Allah. Which is very ironic
that you would try to separates
between the house of Allah and
the messenger of Allah.
However, this is what they did.
Later, when the prophet heard
who had written this document,
he made dua. supplicated
against and it said that his
arm became permanently disabled
for the remainder of his life.
Said
[Silence]
the prophet uncle. The Muslims
from amongst Benny Hashim and
Benny Al Mut Talib. And the non
Muslims alike were all treated
the same. And they were all
forced into that shed. And they
remained there for about three
years. Under
circumstances. Under those
conditions, three years They
remained there and this was in
the around the seventh year
after the prophet was
communicated and sent as a
prophet Seven years after
they were They were forced into
this sheb, into this valley,
and they remained there for 3
years under those conditions.
They endured such hunger and
famine. That anyone who
frequented Mecca, anyone who
walked in any of the streets of
Mecca, at any time of day or
night, it said that this
person, that if you were in any
of the streets of Mecca, day or
night, you could always hear
the faint cries of the children
and women of hunger
there in that sheb.
And so they were under constant
strain for those three years
Three years, they remained
there to the point that it
became almost mythical. The
proportions of their of their
agony
[Silence]
So, here's the thing. There is
a very famous
it's it wasn't really a it
wasn't hung in the Kaaba but
it's it's well deserved of
that. He has a very Abu Talib
had a very distinct poem that
he wrote. And it's referred to
as a La Mia. And he professes
his love for the prophet he
professes his belief in the
prophet message and that he is
a messenger and he acknowledges
that. However, he refuses to
become Muslim. Or to ad here to
Islam. Because of the social
pressures. And because of his
anxiety that he be considered
less in the eyes of his fellow
tribesmen from amongst Quraish
for abandoning their religion
of their forefathers. Abu Talib
died as a non-Muslim according
to the consensus of historians.
As a matter of fact, in
Bukhari, a Muslim his final
words were
Abdul Muktalib. His final words
of this world War, upon
the religion the pagan ways of
Abdul Muttalib, right? Meaning,
I hereby die upon the pagan
ways of of Abdul Muktalib.
These were his final words. The
prophet
discusses this in a few
narrations. In which he speaks
of his intercession. On behalf
of Abu Talib that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala forgive him
anyway That Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala did not forgive Abu
Talib. Instead he lightly
decreased his agony in hell.
However, it was made clear to
the prophet and his companions
that noone who knowingly
rejects Islam and dies upon
that. Having made the decision
to do so will ever be permitted
into paradise and Allah sent
down the verse
a
this verse in
knowingly having chosen making
a choice to die as
disbelievers. and so as this
torment continued as this
famine continued and a person
may think, well, why was there
a famine? I mean, it's just
Quraish. Why didn't they travel
to other parts of the Arab
Peninsula and buy from other
tribes? It's not that easy. As
we said, the influence of
Qureish. Upon the other tribes
throughout the entirety of the
Arab Peninsula was so
overwhelming. That when they
made Hijra, the first and
second time, they had to cross
the Red Sea and flee to a
completely different continent
in order to guarantee or escape
the political reach of Qureish.
All the tribes in Yemen, all of
the tribes in the Arab
Peninsula are not going to
sacrifice their ties with
Quraish over a person that they
don't know. And so if Quraish
decides that we are not going
to do business with these
folks, we are not going to sell
anything to them. We're not
going to buy anything from
them. Not even one grain of
sustenance. If they decide that
and they decide that anyone who
helps them or aids them is one
of them you're going to risk a
lot. You're going to risk even
your tribe's own livelihood,
your own survival, to break
your connections and ties with
Quraish. Because
because is they are the
gatekeepers of Mecca. They are
the gatekeepers of the Kaaba at
that time. And some tribes,
many tribes. We're completely
reliant upon Hajj season for
their livelihood throughout the
year. Imagine that you you have
some trade that you make. and
that usually is going to be one
time a year. Whatever it is,
heroes. Even if you're a
seamstress, even if you're, you
know, even if you're a
blacksmith, whatever. You're
going to travel to Mecca, do
all of your business during
those three months and then
travel home and that's your
livelihood for the rest of the
year. Right? and so you're not
going to risk that for
protecting or dealing with
someone that you don't have any
emotional bond with or even if
you do, it's it's a bad
political move. So, they kind
of shamed and forced everyone
into this agreement. So, they
had nowhere to go to purchase
anything, not even a bag of of
grain. They had nowhere to buy
anything from. This is why
there was a famine. famine took
place During this time because
Abu Talib was wealthy. much
of Beni Hashem and were
wealthy. But if you don't if
you can't find anyone to accept
your money what what good is
the money going to do you?
Right? Money itself does not
secure resources. political
ties can secure resources and
so due to the political reach
of Quraish, a famine ensued
during those three years.
However, They started to have
what I started to experience
some dissonance amongst one
another with regards to the
the anguish that they were
putting their own tribesmen
through and some of them their
own family members through. How
is that? Well, you know, when
they signed this agreement in
the seventh year, they signed
this agreement and they
thought, look, you know, once
they start getting really
hungry, they're going to give
up 6 months, a year. They're
going to abandon him, abandon
Muhammad and will be able to
deal with him swiftly and
everything can go back to
normal. This is what they
expected. but when it dragged
on for a year, 2 years, three
years, their own tribesmen are
dying. They are dying of
malnutrition, their babies are
dying, their children are
dying, this person's
grandchildren, this person's
daughters, this person's, it
started to get really, really,
become more and more
unacceptable to a lot of people
in Quresh. Right? And so,
they, the tribe's leaders, Abu
Jahil, Abu Lahab, these guys
that were instigating this.
Abu Sufian, they started to
experience a lot of dissonance
from the rest of their
tribesmen. look, you
know, this is going on long
enough. Look what we're doing
to these poor people over what?
Right? And so, this dissonance
that started to sprout
throughout Quraish is what
really Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala used to end this
embargo. He says
[Silence]
about the elephant in the room,
right? Look at what we're
doing. This can't be okay. We
don't agree with this. It's
really too bad what we're doing
to our own people and so forth.
And so, The prophet was shown
in a vision or was told by way
of revelation.
that termites had eaten away
this paper that was in the
Kaaba. It's whole agreement.
It's been eaten entirely.
Everything haram in it has been
completely devoured. The only
thing that is left is whatever
part of it has Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala's names in it.
So, the prophet told Abu Talib
about this. Abu Talib took this
as an opportunity
to try to come to try to reach
some kind of resolution and so,
he came as a delegate to the
nobility of Quresh and he said,
look, this is what my nephew
has told me That this agreement
that's in the Kaaba, you guys
know as well as we do, there's
no possible way any of us has
taken a look at it since it was
there. He's told me that it's
completely been eaten away
except for Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala's name. Listen, if that
is the case, you go and check
on it and find that that's
true. Then, relieve us of this
embargo. This has to end. And
if not, if what he said is not
true, we will let you do
whatever you want to.
and so, they went and they
said, you know what? That's
actually very fair. Why? They
were blinded by it being an
opportunity for them to kill
the prophet with impunity. So,
they went arrogantly and looked
at it and found that it was
exactly as Abu Talib told them.
And so, they were shamed into
allowing them back and ending
the embargo. However, in their
hearts, they were increased in
their disbelief and disdain for
Islam and the prophet to
feverish heights. So, this is
enough for tonight inshallah.
We'll continue next week
[Arabic recitation]